from the director who managed to avoid
unnecessary sequels up to this point
comes a completely unnecessary sequel
only this time it's the second time the
lost world
Jurassic Park shouldn't that title be
the other way around no okay
loved Jurassic Park for its all
inspiring wander subtle humor and
likable characters now get ready for a
generic run away from dinosaurs movie
with more deaths more dangling vehicles
and more giant practical t-rex heads
passing next to things
and pushing into things
and moving behind things because those
heads cost a ton and Spielberg is going
to get his money's worth damn it meet a
cast of humans who still haven't learned
one thing from the first time I'm not
making the same mistakes again you're
making all new ones featuring the return
of your favorite wisecracking side
character from Jurassic Park ah as a
boring neurotic dad that has my feelings
your mom Talia Sarah who's just there to
rattle off the trailer lines no he's
very angry proving once and for all that
a little Golu goes a long way you'll
have to get used to dr. Malcolm he
suffers from a deplorable excessive
tussin arabic along for the ride is
Ian's daughter do you see any family
resemblance and a gymnast and total slob
who was personally responsible for the
low point of the franchise
okay second lowest point Allen then get
to know Ian's paleontologist girlfriend
Sarah she's the worst watch is this
bumbling miss Magoo constantly harasses
the dinosaurs steals a baby t-rex that
gets toby from the West Wing killed
walks around with t-rex blood on her
jacket even though she's supposed to
know better
Tyrannosaurus got the large portion all
factory cavity of any creature in the
fossil record
and generally makes life harder on
everyone else around her Sarah wait are
we supposed to be rooting for the
dinosaurs or the people stare helplessly
as the creatures were once treated with
reverence and restraint are transformed
into over-the-top killing machines where
the mighty t-rex becomes a generic
monster and the claustrophobic Raptor
kitchen scene from the first film
becomes Jurassic Benny Hill
you
so try to enjoy the ride then try to
enjoy the climax to the ride that feels
like it was bolted on from a different
movie as Spielberg runs out of things
for dinosaurs to do in the jungle and
ships one off to San Diego for a
20-minute Godzilla parity in an extended
dinosaur money shot that we all thought
had killed the franchise but we had no
idea what was coming Alan starring um oh
yes yes
Julianne lass Vince yawn Santa Claus
mckayla maroney
is not impressed Pete post-split the
wait postlets wait puffs lethwei t a
screw it Kobayashi Oedipus Rex and a
whale's vagina
to Jurassic to furious
we'll be bigger and better than Jurassic
Park I can't imagine anything being
bigger than that Jurassic Park but I
don't know it will be as good as it is
ya know
yep pretty much be sure to subscribe for
more honest trailers
I backed Koopa balls Kickstarter the
human touch was denied a bank loan got
any grapes lyin' lyin' lyin' lyin' lyin'
lyin' lyin' lyin' I can't believe he
chose this comment shop smart shop a
smart